essentially love when a game just comes
out of nowhere and absolutely blows you
away
imagine for a moment if you took
bloodborne Bioshock and Pinocchio mash
them all together the result would be
something pretty close to lies of p a
new upcoming action RPG from South
Korean publisher Neo is I recently tried
out the demo for the game and honestly I
am pretty Blown Away guys people love
the internet retro wrecking tour here
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and up until a few
weeks ago I had never even heard of Liza
P I was actually on vacation during the
summer game Fest but one game that I
kept hearing about was Liza p and also
that they released a demo so this past
week I mean without looking at any
footage whatsoever I decided to download
the demo give it a try and wow there's
just one tiny tiny little thing I think
it's missing but we'll get to that so as
soon as you put up the game the main
menu will materialize on the screen and
it really helps to set the tone for what
you're about to play on the right you
have this mechanical Golden Heart which
you can hear clicking in addition to the
thunderstorm and then the somber piano
tune playing as well I mean I know it's
just a menu but there was something
about it that really sort of set the
mood for me the demo begins when our
protagonist p is awakened by a
mysterious voice which asks the player
to make their way to hotel krot and
promises more information about what's
going on once we arrive before making
your way to the hotel you'll get to
choose one of three classes each
offering a distinct starting weapon this
Choice significantly impacts the
gameplay experience allowing players to
tailor their approach to combat in fact
I'm even thinking about going and
playing through again as one of these
other classes to really get a feel for
how they're different as you begin to
venture through the Grim streets of crot
you'll see it was a once vibrant City
that's now been tainted by Madness and
bloodlust the inspiration of both
Bioshock and bloodborne will be
incredibly clear here to anyone who's
played those games and as I mentioned in
the intro lies of p is actually a
retelling of the classic story of
Pinocchio and here's an area where I
actually think it may have even more
appeal than something like bloodborne
which I absolutely loved it's one of my
favorite games ever made let's be honest
the story not exactly an easy one to
follow Liza P takes the essence of the
classic Pinocchio story but with a Twist
which should offer a fresh and exciting
take on the Beloved tale throughout the
game The Echoes of the original
Pinocchio story ReSound within the city
of krat setting characters and even the
loading screens pay homage to the
classic story so we eventually learned
the mysterious voice belongs to someone
named Sophia and she warns that the city
streets are far from safe so you'll end
up encountering a few basic enemy Types
on your way to the hotel most of these
enemies are puppets and mechanical in
nature but neowiz promises all sorts of
monsters in the final game with puppets
only being one of many they also
promised that in the final game you'll
encounter a diverse cast of characters
each harboring their own motivations and
secrets some may offer guidance and aid
while Others May seek to exploit P for
their own game and you do get to meet a
few of these in the demo the atmosphere
of lies of p is a hauntingly beautiful
tribute to the Bella poke era despite
the city's descent into darkness
remnants of its former glory still
resonate through the decaying
architecture that showcases both the
Allure and despair of a world corrupted
by lies and speaking of Lies this is one
mechanic and Liza P that I'm very
curious to know more about you see p is
crafted from a puppet's heart yet he
yearns to understand what it means to
think and feel like a human there will
be choices throughout the game where you
can give Comfort to those who are
suffering by lying or you can choose to
tell the truth each decision shapes P's
character and Alters the course of the
narrative are you a puppet or a human
and that question is so fascinating to
me especially as I think more about the
demo are you a puppet or a human what
exactly do they mean by puppet because
in the demo I'm not going to spoil the
exact choices but the characters
basically tell you that you need to lie
at least in one of the situations and I
just went ahead and lied didn't even
think about it being an option to say
the other one and so then I started
thinking about wait am I a puppet to
them am I just doing exactly what they
say does the game want me to tell the
truth instead but if you tell the truth
it's very kind of cold-hearted in some
instances the second choice oh man I
like to think of myself I'm a pretty
truthful person I do not lie however in
this situation I straight up lied to
this person because in my mind it was
was much better to lie to them than
actually tell them what was a pretty
gruesome truth the demo is impressively
extensive boasting a pretty substantial
amount of content for players to explore
I spent about five hours trying to see
and do everything plus yes I did die a
handful of times I would say even
experienced Souls players will have a
couple of deaths especially on the
bosses I'm still trying to decide how I
feel about the difficulty overall
initially I thought oh wow this is way
too easy and even when I was dying early
it was very clear why I was dying but
then I reached the final boss of the
demo of which there are three total
bosses here and each of these encounters
really did provide a unique challenge
the first one felt pretty balanced for
what I assume is going to be the first
boss fight in the final game as well the
second one though way too easy
especially once you realize that he can
be backstabbed just over and over and
over backstab backstab backstab I
thought the third boss was by far the
most challenging and the one that
required the most knowledge of the
game's combat system I thought this demo
just did such a great job of showcasing
the core elements and the gameplay
mechanics that really show how this
could be a standout title and definitely
one you should have on your radar now
speaking of gameplay I thought it felt
really good overall and just when you
feel like you understand everything the
game will throw another layer at you and
so it kind of keeps adding on this even
throughout the demo so I can't imagine
once you get the final game in your
hands how many layers upon layers upon
layers there's going to be but this is a
very good thing I think and it did this
gradually I thought the demo really
handled it well in terms of how they
introduced these new mechanics to you
and even still left enough that's kind
of a mystery in fact even when the demo
ends you can still kind of go around and
explore and you can actually see some of
the upgrades that you're gonna be able
to get in the final game and then there
are some other ones that you can't see
at all you just know they're there so I
think the combat is really something
that's going to just get deeper and
deeper as you go if you've played any of
the souls games particularly bloodborne
you're gonna feel right at home here and
at the same time I do think there are
enough tweaks that differentiate it from
The Souls games make no mistake though
this game is unabashedly inspired by
from software and you'll see that
throughout the demo and presumably the
final game as well so R1 is going to be
used for your light attacks R2 for heavy
attacks L1 box and then you have L2
which controls your mechanical left arm
and speaking of upgrades you can get
upgrades for what they call the legion
arm it starts out as just this strong
melee attack but later on I found an
item that modified it into being able to
Grapple enemies it like shoots out this
Harpoon and then there's another
electric one that I found toward the
very end okay blocking and pairing this
is a really interesting system here and
you can see they've sort of combined
elements from sekiro and bloodborne so
if you just hold L1 You'll Use Your
Weapon to block and the stats of the
weapon you're holding plus the enemy
that's going to determine how much
damage that you'll actually be able to
block I actually went with the path of
the sweeper class for the demo which is
the one focused on strength so my weapon
was this large great sword and it
blocked a fair amount of damage on every
hit okay now here's where things start
to get interesting remember bloodborne
system that allowed you to attack
shortly after getting hit and regain
some of your health Liza P has a very
similar system in place but with a Twist
you'll only be able to regain a portion
of the health back if you're blocking so
if you take a hit without blocking you
can't regain any of that Health back by
attacking you'll have to heal normally
oh and did I also mention the enemies
they can do this too in fact they don't
even have to attack you to start
regaining some of their health that's
right every enemy in the game and it
really encourages you to stay aggressive
so you're not just gonna run off and
hide in the corner now I feel like this
is balanced out by not giving the enemy
the ability to fully heal at least the
enemies that I encountered in the game
and you'll be able to tell by looking at
that section that's sort of grayed out
now to add a further wrinkle to this the
game also has a parrying system so if
you manage to time your block at just
the right moment you'll block 100 of the
attack and not take any damage at all oh
yeah remember how I said there's one
thing missing there's no satisfying
repost one of my favorite things to do
in bloodborne and one of the components
that made that combat feel so satisfying
was hitting your shot at just the right
time and then moving in for the visceral
attack now there is sort of a version of
this we'll get to that here in a second
and who knows maybe there will be
something later on you unlock that's
going to enable a special attack
immediately after parrying but right now
at least to me it just doesn't feel like
you're rewarded for landing that perfect
Parry against the basic enemies to me it
offer some risk but not much reward at
least with how I currently understand
the system I think you're just better
off dodging against these standard
enemies boss fights definitely a
different story though I really
struggled with this third boss until I
finally started getting the timing down
on the parries more consistently now all
that being said there is a way to put
the enemy in a vulnerable state and open
them up to a more powerful
visceral-like attack the game refers to
this as a groggy State and you can
trigger it by doing a Charged strong
attack anytime you see their HP bar
highlighted in white after landing that
charged attack you'll see a red symbol
that appears on the enemy which means
they're set up for a fatal attack that
you execute by facing the enemy and
pressing R1 as for what triggers that
groggy State and the change in the
health bar I think there's a hidden
posture bar system here very similar to
what Eldon ring had although I would
like to do a little more testing to be
exactly sure what makes that highlight
appear I know you can trigger it just by
attacking a lot but I think perfect
parries may add to this as well now if
you're wondering about this meter over
here on the right that is the sharpness
of your weapon you'll need to keep an
eye on this a lot especially actually
anytime you're going into a big fight
you want to make sure that it's fully
sharpened it's essentially a weapon
durability system so your weapon is
going to drop anytime you attack or
block Landing a perfect Parry though
does not result in a loss of durability
which is just yet another example of how
important pairing is going to be in this
game you do have a default item called
the grinder that will sharpen your
weapon and you can use this even in the
middle of battle this aspect of the
combat is one I'm still honestly not
sure how I feel about overall it's not
like other games where your weapon is
going to completely break and it's lost
forever and I have to say it definitely
adds an additional layer to combat
though because you have to make sure you
don't let the weapon completely break if
it happens in a boss fight even though
there's a way to fully repair it you
just aren't going to realistically have
enough time to use it with any sort of
powerful enemy nearby and all of that is
just the basics of combat there are so
many more layers to it you should
definitely check out the demo for
yourself I've actually uploaded my full
playthrough over on my let's play
Channel I'll link it here on the right
side of the screen now check it out next
as always guys thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon